[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette à proximité de Tokyo au Japon que
ce sont déroulés les championnats du
monde de patinage de vitesse
[Musique]
le sprinter soviétique grishing que l'on
voit ici en pleine action a remporté le
500 mètres mais la grande vedette de ces
championnats c'est le Suédois Johnny
Nilsson qui s'est permis le luxe de
battre trois records du monde au cours
de ces championnats
d'ailleurs d'une façon générale les
Nordiques ont repris leur suprématie sur
les Soviétiques actuellement en déclin
si la glace rend les bateaux
inutilisables elle a du moins l'avantage
de rendre les canaux carrossables ainsi
ont résonné les automobilistes
hollandais qui ont trouvé de la sorte
une compensation aux rayures
exceptionnelles de l'hiver
jalonné par des stations services
mobiles une nouvelle route s'est ouverte
à travers le zuderzé et personne n'a
regretté le ferry boat
[Musique]
il est bon de temps en temps de
retrouver un terrain solide sous ses pas
quand on est condamné à vivre sur l'eau
c'est ce que deux mois de gel ont offert
au
les footballeurs français ont attendu
presque un an et demi pour renouer avec
la victoire voici le début signé
vizneywski du festival offensive de
l'équipe de France face à l'Angleterre
au Parc des Princes à Paris
et de deux douilles en effet ajoute un
second but à l'actif de l'attaque
française il est vrai que les défenseurs
britanniques lancent et maladroits
pratiquent le football de grand papa le
coup de grâce avant la mi-temps un
troisième but que marque cossu les
Anglais cependant un peu mortifiés ont
essayé de forcer le destin dès le début
de la seconde mi-temps ils sont parvenus
à remonter deux buts au moment où ils
ont l'espoir d'égaliser business qui
leur
donne le coup et puis pour faire bonne
mesure et pour prouver que l'équipe de
France est sur la bonne voie Koso ajoute
un cinquième but ce sera le dernier 5 à
[Musique]
le Salon des Arts Ménagers 80.000 m²
1800 exposants faites cette année son
40e anniversaire 40 ans d'armes ménagers
c'est assez pour remplir une
encyclopédie et même plusieurs devant
pareil Yama de savoir et de savoir-faire
codifier Montaigne serait aujourd'hui
comblée lui qui disait la plus utile et
honorable science et occupations pour
une femme c'est la science du ménage il
avait évidemment oublié le célibataire
visiteurs consciencieux c'est à lui sans
nul doute que le Salon des Arts Ménagers
offre le plus d'occasion de rêver son
cœur et David de confort sa soif de
découvrir est inépuisable et que ne
réserve pas un miroir
Saint-Gobain offre un aperçu des
multiples rôles que le verre peut jouer
dans un foyer
[Musique]
le vert est glace mais il est aussi
isolant si les greniers ne sont guère
habités de nos jours par les fantômes
ils le sont encore par les courants
d'air un simple revêtement de laine de
verre permet d'ishaler les toits et de
gagner ainsi une pièce d'habitation dans
la maison autant ou la crise du logement
ne semble pas encore résolue voici donc
une solution astucieuse et amusante à la
portée du bricolage
et le vert c'est encore des verres à
boire bien sûr mais aussi des plats des
assiettes aux formes nouvelles qui
peuvent être mises entre toutes les
mains même les plus maladroites les
armes ménagées le voilà bien le paradis
du célibataire
[Musique]
on va construire une cité à Hérouville
c'est-à-dire plusieurs quartiers autour
d'un centre avec son commerce et son
administration pour la circulation plus
de Carrefour des branches en y
les voitures ne rentrent pas dans les
quartiers réservés aux piétons mais il
faut tout voir pour comprendre
l'urbanisme alors reprenons au début et
suivant l'opération qui se prépare près
de Caen pour répondre à des besoins
immédiats quand ville en expansion a
créé tout un secteur d'habitation mais
il ne suffit pas de loger un plan
d'urbanisme lui doit aller plus loin
l'urbanisme moderne a maintenant pour
but de créer des villes qui répondent
aux quatre fonctions logées travaillées
circulaient se cultiver mais dans ces
villes édifiées de toutes pièces il faut
permettre comme autrefois
l'épanouissement de toutes les activités
pourraient aux villes la société
d'équipements de Basse Normandie a mis
en concours le plan d'une ville de 40000
habitants sur ce terrain de 300 hectares
elle va être construite en fonction de
différents pôles d'attractions les
usines existantes et les zones
industrielles ou plusieurs milliers
d'emplois vont être créés à quelques
minutes du lieu d'habitation
[Musique]
et son université qui ajoutera au
potentiel intellectuel de la ville de
demain
et aussi la mer à quelques kilomètres
[Musique]
Hérouville se dressera sur ses prairies
et le projet de l'Union d'architecte et
d'urbanisme prévoit la ville avec un
cintre lié à six quartiers différents un
parc est des jardins des volumes variés
cet ensemble a été modelé sur le terrain
et sa silhouette et celle d'une ville de
l'importance de Chartres
l'élément de base de la ville est le
quartier dont les 5000 habitants peuvent
se connaître le chauffeur peut être
courtois car la circulation est continue
à sens unique sans croisement ni feu
quittons la route qu'aucun immeuble ne
borne après la passerelle qui nous mène
au quartier importite nous réserve la
surprise d'une place vous ne connaissez
pas ce genre de place car ici tout est
calme pas de voiture l'homme est dans
son milieu
l’espace se resserre pour retrouver le
coup d'accoud d'une rue marchande
full l'horizon se dégage la verdure
resurgit pour salir à la pierre grâce à
ses nouveaux principes d'urbanisme
Hérouville va répondre au désir de tous
ses habitants quelle que soit leur
profession leur façon de vivre leur âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le crédit est roi pour un
achat de quelqu'un d'importance le
paiement comptant est devenu l'exception
la traitement Suède est entrée dans les
habitudes
[Musique]
mais il est un domaine où le crédit
n'avait pas encore été appliqué celui de
la contrainte par corps en Belgique le
ministre de la Justice monsieur vermelen
vient de mettre à laisser un système de
prison à tempérament cet homme par
exemple coupable d'un délit mineur a été
condamné à deux semaines de prison il
est libre il travaille mais il va
s'acquitter de sa dette pendant ses
congés hebdomadaires chaque samedi à 14h
il quitte son foyer discrètement son
employeur ses amis ne savent rien seul
sa femme est au courant il passera deux
nuits et la journée du dimanche en
prison
[Musique]
le lundi à 6h du matin il sera libre de
nouveau sa vie familiale est intacte sa
dignité n'a pas souffert dans quelques
semaines il sera redevenu un homme comme
les autres
à force de France comme chaque année le
carnaval du Mardi Gras a déroulé ses
faces à travers les rues de la ville une
foulardinte et bigarrée a défilé pendant
des heures en wagons au rythme des
Calypso et des béguines toutes les
barrières sociales ont disparu un seul
mot d'ordre s'amuser
[Musique]
et le lendemain mercredi des Cendres par
une exception unique aux Antilles la
foule martiniquaise s'est retrouvée sur
la place de la savane uniformément vêtue
de noir et de blanc couleur de deuil
pour l'enterrement du carnaval
comme on dit ici Vava les morts carnaval
est mort mais pour un an seulement
[Applaudissements]
en France une semaine s'est achevée sur
la grève des mineurs sans qu'aucun signe
de reprise et pu être décelé
dans leur défilé au contraire les
mineurs ont confirmé leur détermination
[Applaudissements]
d'un bout à l'autre des bassins miniers
les trains sont demeurerrés mobiles et
les roues défausses n'ont pas repris
leur mouvement sinon pour les services
de sécurité dans les réunions qu'ils ont
tenu les mineurs ont fait de la levée de
la réquisition un préalable à toute
prise du travail
[Musique]
les mères des communes minières de
Lorraine de leur côté se sont associés
aux manifestations et les orateurs se
sont préoccupés de la revalorisation de
la profession de mineur
et malgré les paroles apaisantes du
Premier ministre la situation au 11e
jour de la grève n'avait pas évolué
[Musique]
un mois après Bagdad coup d'État
militaire à Damart tandis que les chars
aux ordres du Conseil révolutionnaire
contrôlaient la rue c'est à l'ambassade
de Turquie que le chef du gouvernement
monsieur Khaled et lazem avait trouvé
refuge
reconnu par l'Egypte le Conseil de la
Révolution a manifesté dès le lendemain
du coup de force c'est sympathie
prenacerienne comme le firent
précisément les auteurs du putschirach
l'unité arabe semble devoir être aussi
au programme de Monsieur Salah habitat
chef du nouveau cabinet syrien installé
par les militaires
pour 10 états de l'Amérique du Nord leur
printanière du dégel s'est traduite par
l'assaut général des eaux hors des lits
des rivières et voici le drame qu'a vécu
de façon particulièrement intense un
jeune habitant de l'Ohio heureusement un
hélicoptère veille
[Musique]
le jeune homme en fut quitte pour la
peur tous n'ont pas eu cette chance on a
eu à déplorer 18 victimes
à New York les eaux death River ont
causé la mort brutale de cet ouvrier
pénible bilan d'un fait divers peu
commun la chute dans la rivière d'un car
transportant les employés d'un hôpital
[Musique]
à sortir vivant de ce bain forcé due on
le suit par la suite à un accident
cardiaque survenu au conducteur
[Musique]
Édouard Belin Savin français n'est plus
sans doute le grand public ne s'est-il
plus ce qu'il doit se petit homme qui
habitait le démon de l'invention dès
1907 il inventa le bélinographe qui
préfigurait la future télévision à
laquelle il avait d'ailleurs consacré
des travaux c'est grâce à cette
invention que les clichés parviennent en
quelques minutes aujourd'hui
ou transmetteur déjà mis au point en
1913 par Edouard Belin la photo
transformée en variation de courant
franchit les distances pour se
reproduire sur le bellino-récepteur
[Musique]
Belin fut le premier au monde à
transmettre des images à distance
[Musique]
avec le printemps la Parisienne change
de tête chez Serge Stern de large
mouvement souple et naturel
Henri menu dégage la nuque et cultive la
symétrie
Antoine Salvador reste fidèle au bandeau
alors que George Méry leur préfère une
certaine fluidité dans le volume les
mèches seront plus courtes avec des
mouvements mèches chez Pierre Charly
plus contrastées chez Jean sarfato
[Musique]
c'est dans le cadre prestigieux de
l'Opéra de Paris que 40 mannequins ont
présenté les dernières créations de la
Haute Coiffure Française la tendance est
à la simplicité
le style aiglon domine avec toutefois
beaucoup d'interprétations personnelles
mais le drame est un parfois de passer
inaperçu il y aura toujours des
irréductibles
l'élégance du chef n'exclut pas le
velouté de la main pour le conserver à
travers les servitudes ménagères voici
une nouveauté présentée en Hollande le
gant a épluché les pommes de terre cette
paille de fer parmentière permet d'un
simple massage de débarrasser les
tubercules en tout genre de leur
enveloppe champêtre désormais se frotter
les mains devient pour la cuisinière un
geste fonctionnel voilà qui ouvre aussi
des perspectives inédites sur la
traditionnelle corvée de plus
en V de printemps pour cette ambitieux
bavarois qui avec les beaux jours
espèrent retrouver la sveltesse de son
adolescence rien ne lui était parié pour
tenter d'éliminer les disgracieuses
conséquences des excès de la table
mort à la cellulite pas de pitié pour le
bourrelet
où sont plus faciles à gagner qu'à
perdre et le retour a des proportions à
Pologne nés sans doute pas pour demain
[Musique]
craindre pour cette athlète espagnol qui
doit soulever 20 fois en une minute ce
cylindre de 125 kg un des numéros les
plus caractéristiques des escolaris les
jeux sportifs de Saint-Sébastien
[Applaudissements]
celui-ci semble prendre un certain
plaisir à faire rouler d'épaule à
épaules une petite mappemonde de 200 kg
exploit digne du géant Atlas qui s'était
offert le luxe de soulever le globe
l'épreuve de la descente du Candahar a
brillamment couronné la saison
internationale de ski sur la piste Verte
des Houches le mur une cassure brutale
de la ligne de pente constitue l'une des
difficultés majeures après de 100 à
l'heure le skieur est catapulté vers le
goulet
le goulet en voici l'entrée est un
passage étroit une sorte de gouttière ou
tout freinage est impossible le
concurrent il peut suivre qu'une seule
direction celle de la ligne de plus
grande pente
[Musique]
troisième difficulté le shoes de la fils
un passage en forêt ponctué de
nombreuses bosses qui secouent
douloureusement les musculatures déjà
éprouvées par 1500 mètres de course
telle est au-dessus de Chamonix la Verte
des Houches l'une des pistes les plus
difficiles du monde
[Musique]
seul un grand athlète pouvait remporter
les preuves je devait être l'allemand de
l'Ouest ludwich light
il a vécu la chance de partir en 12e
position c'est-à-dire avec des
conditions de visibilité acceptable sur
l'ensemble du parcours alors que les
premiers à partir au nombre desquelles
schrans la croix est Minch s'était
trouvé par moment en plein brouillard
[Musique]
remarquablement en jambes lightner
trouvait exactement la bonne ligne il
passait sans difficulté tous les
obstacles en s'efforçant de conserver
cette position aérodynamique mise au
point par les Français et désormais
universellement utilisés
[Musique]
dans la dernière ligne droite lightner
va rétablir miraculeusement son
équilibre un instant compromis
et c'est avec prio que c'est autrichien
naturalisé allemand va apporter à son
pays d'adoption sa première grande
victoire de la saison en dessin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
honoré Bonnel entraîneur des Français a
lieu d'être également satisfait il
classe 13 hommes dans les 20 premiers
parmi lesquels Jean-Claude Killy 19 ans
qui prend la deuxième place
monsieur Maurice Herzog et les
spectateurs venus le lendemain assister
au slalom devait avoir le privilège
d'assister au récital de François
Bonlieu dans son style très personnel
tout délégance et de faciliter bon lieu
s'imposait de bout en bout une cadence
extrêmement rapide
[Musique]
c'est avec une bonne seconde d'avance
sur son ami peyriaque François Bonlieu a
enlevait ce slalom du candard bon lieu
prenait également la première place du
combiné ce qui lui valait la récompense
suprême le cas de diamant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une visite éclair que le général
de Gaulle a fait un Hollande où tu as
déjeuné de la famille royale le
Président et Madame De Gaulle ont passé
quelques heures au château de Wiston
Bosch en compagnie de la reine Juliana
du prince Bernard des trois princesses
Béatrix Irène et margritte et du
ministre des Affaires étrangères
monsieur Loon
cette visite dont on a remarqué la
cordialité a contribué à détendre
l'atmosphère diplomatique qui régnait
entre les deux pays depuis la rupture
des négociations de Bruxelles sur
l'entrée de l'Angleterre dans le marché
commun
[Musique]
l'industrie des matières plastiques
connaît en France un développement
saisissant l'implantation de tels usines
dans diverses régions françaises à
contribué à l'expansion industrielle
mais un développement industriel
constant à l'échelon national 50 000
usines et ateliers créés depuis 10 ans
ne se conçoit que dans un grand
mouvement de capitaux c'est ici que le
Crédit national joue un rôle essentiel
sorte de pompe aspirante et foulante de
capitaux il offre à l'économie une
source constante d'investissement donc
d'extension dans tous les domaines y
compris bien entendu celui de
l'industrie lourde
des réalisations remarquables traduisent
la vitalité de ce secteur l'utilisation
simultanée de trois fours à arc
électrique produisant une qualité
d'acier identique a récemment permis
d'obtenir en France une coulée record la
plus importante obtenue en Europe et qui
permet de mouler directement des cages
de laminoir de 240 tonnes
[Applaudissements]
les problèmes sociaux demeurent
préoccupants en France transporté par
360 véhicules divers 2000 ouvriers des
mines de fer de Lorraine ont participé à
la marche sur Paris cette démonstration
destinée à alerter l'opinion publique
aura constitué la manifestation la plus
spectaculaire de la grève des mineurs
qui étaient entré dans sa troisième
semaine
[Musique]
pour 24 heures les cheminots à leur tour
s'engagaient dans la grève et des
menaces d'arrêt de travail semblaient
peser sur tout le secteur nationalisé
au 17e jour de leur mouvement alors que
l'on croyait une issue proche les
mineurs des charbonnages se sont réunis
à Lens au nombre de 40 000 au cours d'un
grand meeting
cependant des consultations entreprises
à Paris auprès des responsables
syndicaux par le comité des sages
laissaient la porte ouverte au dialogue
et du même coup à la possibilité d'un
règlement de la crise
[Musique]
tout a commencé à mon arrivée à Paris il
y a trois ans en raison des événements
je vais quitté le Vietnam au pays natal
avec mon enfant j'étais seule je n'avais
pas d'argent je ne connaissais personne
à Paris j'avais seulement un numéro de
téléphone celui d'un organisateur de
concours de beauté il accepta de me voir
il me donne un rendez-vous dans un café
il décida de s'occuper de moi et un mois
plus tard le 31 décembre 1960 j'étais
élue Miss France c'était merveilleux
mais c'était trop beau c'était un rêve
je n'ai pas voulu signer le contraste
scandaleux de mon organisateur et bien
il m'a destitué sous prétexte que
j'avais triché sur mon âge et que
j'avais un enfant alors tout s'écroula
dans mon quartier j'étais l'objet des
conversations c'était affreux voilà mon
histoire
mais Luceau j'ai réagi devant le
tribunal civil de Versailles et langage
une action contre le comité Miss France
maître blatteau lassiste
une autre Miss France Brigitte barazzer
vient témoigner le tribunal a donné
raison à lui sauver car elle a démontré
qu'en posant sa candidature elle avait
produit son passeport ou son âge et sa
situation de famille était portée
Brigitte barazzer aussi a une opinion
bien établie Miss France 60 je crois
quels sont vos grillettes à vous contre
les organisateurs des concours de beauté
bien toute la légende des belles robes
quand on arrive à la salle de restaurant
on prend trois menus pour 4 pour faire
des économies et on ramasse les restes
exactement votre propos
était évidemment de défendre des
intérêts de ma cliente mais je voudrais
surtout par cette audience à tirer
l'attention des jeunes filles de France
sur la prudence qui convient lorsqu'elle
participent à des concours pour ce titre
de Miss
[Musique]
fillette attention le chemin qui mène à
ces royaumes tes éphémères et semer de
plus de chardons que de fleurs de lys
[Musique]
avec ses nouveaux quartiers quadrillés à
l'américaine ou pointe de si de la
building Lima capitale du Pérou offre
dès la mort l'image même d'une de ces
cités à la mode du Nouveau Monde les
vestiges d'une antique construction de
l'Empire InCar réduit à un monticule de
terre n’influa sur cette première
impression que suscite cette capitale
vouée à la civilisation de l'automobile
à Lima pourtant à l'inverse de Buenos
Aires le présent n'a pas entièrement
recouvert le passé il y a quatre siècles
François pizza fixa sur les bords
désertiques du remake la capitale de sa
conquête et il créa de toutes pièces une
ville à l'espagnol
mais ces quatre siècles n'ont pas suffi
à effacer l'amour des balcons Andalous
d'autant plus insolites cependant qu'il
contribue à masquer une lumière déjà
voilée huit mois durant par le
brouillard du Pacifique
à l'ombre du plus beau d'entre eux
dorment les souvenirs de la vie royauté
au long de la rue dédiée aux dernières
Incas c'est encore l'Espagne qu'évoque
les oliviers 4 69 sous lesquels les
limmeniennes déguste le maïs et les
limoniens la chicha alcool extrait du
maïs
[Musique]
20 l'heure de l'indépendance l'humain a
dédié au libérateur du Pérou procès de
San Martin l'une des plus monumentales
de ces places comme elle en a dédiée une
autre au héros national de la guerre du
Pacifique l'amiral grahao mais ici
encore le présent s'ajoute au passé et
le dimanche devant l'église on ne
s’éteindra pas de voir la mentielle
encadrée uniformément des visages que le
brassage des races a rendus bien
différents
[Musique]
plus que n'importe quel autre monument
les églises évoquent la splendeur du
passé lors légendaire des Incas hybrides
tous ces feux
au voyageur d'aujourd'hui Lima offre de
singulier contraste la tentation des
immeubles modernes a fait surgir des
architectures rectilignes à côté
d'architecture ancienne et c'est tout à
la fois l'avenir le présent et le passé
qui se mêle
seul le vieux Lima résiste encore à la
surcharge des siècles encore qu'il soit
envahi par les automobiles
[Musique]
de leur passé espagnol les limoniens ont
gardé une passion intacte la corrida
il s'y révèle des spectateurs assidus
d'autant plus que le Pacifique vers
lequel toutes les grandes avenues
convergent n'offrent qu'une eau trop
froide aux jolies baigneuses de l'été
austral
[Musique]
pôle d'attraction de tout l'arrière pays
Lima en est aussi la victime du haut des
collines dévalent de curiosités humaines
petit cube fait de treillis recouverts
ce sont les bariadas chaque mois des
familles d'Indiens descendants de la
montagne augmentent la population de
cette ville parasite qui s'accroche à
Lima phénomène propre à toutes les
grandes capitales du monde cette
migration prend ici un caractère
intensif et la capitale péruvienne qui
pourtant construit vite et beaucoup ne
peut absorber ce spectaculaire
accroissement de population
71 espagnols et 200 indiens autant de
pizzas 95
000 habitants 1850 Lima compte
aujourd'hui 2 millions d'armes
[Musique]
on conçoit qu'en période électorale les
courants politiques puissent trouver ici
de multiples résonances
l'armée a gardé l'habitude
hérité de 142 ans d'indépendance
d'arbitrer les situations devenues
délicates au Palais du gouvernement ou
veille des gardes républicains à la
France il est ainsi assez courant de
voir s'installer une jante militaire ce
fut le cas en juillet dernier et cette
jante vient d'obtenir la démission de
son chef le général Perez Godoy suspect
de vouloir s'opposer aux élections
prévues pour le mois de juin
dans la vie de Lima les élections sont
toujours l'occasion d'une grande
agitation de rue des cortèges
impressionnants se forment autour des
noms des candidats à la présidence et
tous les six ans les limonias apportent
là la même passion que celle qu'il
manifeste à la corrida ou au match de
football
[Musique]
de la marine américaine c'est la grande
aventure qui commence près de 4000
mètres de chute libre et pendant une
minute c'est le temps qu'il leur faut
pour effectuer leur descente ils
évoluent dans le ciel comme des oiseaux
des oiseaux un peu malhabiles il est
vrai ce rendez-vous de l'espace n'est
pas aussi simple qu'il y paraît la
caméra qui suit les hommes volants
trichent sur la vitesse
elle tourne au ralenti
les deux hommes tournois acrobatiquement
dans le ciel en filant vers le sol à
plus de 200 km à l'heure
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et si les parachutes ne s'ouvraient pas
[Musique]
ouf ça se termine bien quand même et
chacun des hommes volants atterrit
exactement sur la cible fixée avant le
départ
[Musique]
mettre le patrimoine artistique de
l'humanité entre toutes les mains c'est
le but de la nouvelle revue hebdomadaire
qu'on lançait au musée des Monuments
français du Trocadéro deux enfants au
nom célèbres Paloma Picasso et Aline
Cézanne une manifestation très
parisienne autour de 40 000 ans de
chef-d'œuvre à laquelle participer le
Tout-Paris des arts et le ministre de
l'information Monsieur à l'interfi
[Musique]
le tout New York s'est penché sur
l'avenir vestimentaire des VIP entendez
des personnages très importants ce sont
d'ailleurs ces personnages très
importants qui présentaient eux-mêmes
les modèles de la nouvelle collection le
printemps en complet classique Big Mac
grêle junior président de la Société
flag Utica
Henri Le King directeur du New York hors
magazine un vêtement de sport
je suis d'elle président des magasins
Kodak en blaser et pantalon de flanelle
rayé
[Musique]
essayez maintenant d'imaginer nos
présidents directeurs généraux
présentant eux-mêmes leur mode
[Applaudissements]
vraiment l'Amérique n'a pas fini de nous
étonner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en France les problèmes sociaux restent
à l'ordre du jour par deux fois quatre
heures de grève des employés de l'EDF en
privé Paris de courant et les carrefours
de feu de signalisation il en est
résulté un certain nombre
d'embouteillages
[Musique]
embouteillage rue de Rivoli ou les
fonctionnaires ont défilé de l'Hôtel de
Ville au ministère des Finances pour
réclamer eux aussi une augmentation de
salaire
[Musique]
à Marseille
2500 mineurs sont venus du bassin de
Provence pour manifester
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la grève des mineurs en était à sa
quatrième semaine et on attendait une
solution de la réunion des syndicats et
de la direction des charbonnages mais
les mineurs ayant jugé insuffisantes les
propositions qui leur avaient été faites
les négociations sont dans l'impasse
[Musique]
au Japon le printemps a mal commencé
pour la petite ville côtière de nous la
pluie et la fonte des neiges ont miné la
colline voisine et des tonnes de terre
ont déferlé vers la mer
à la sortie d'un tunnel un train a été
happé par miracle on a compté que si
blessé léger et de disparu alors que
certains wagons ont été transpercé par
des arbres
une soixantaine de maisons ont été
également détruites mais les habitants
de nous ont pris la chose avec
philosophie c'est toujours pareil au
printemps du style
il y a maintenant un an qu'à la table
verte de l'Hôtel du Parc les accords
d'Évian ont mis un terme au conflit
algérien mais au milieu des soubresauts
qu'entraînaient la fin d'un tel drame
une partie importante de la population
européenne d'Algérie ne vit d'autre
issues que dans son départ
650 000 personnes partir pour la
métropole
au-delà des secours immédiats qui
répondirent au désarroi du déracinement
se trouvait posé à plus longue échéance
un problème d'intégration d'une ampleur
sans précédent telle est l'opération
d'entreprise aujourd'hui par Monsieur
missof ministre des rapatriés
il s'agit de réaliser l'intégration à
l'économie nationale de 100 000
rapatriés ils savent bien tous que leur
dignité exige qu'il participe à la vie
active et nous se contente pas d'une
assistance qui serait nécessairement
éphémère
une telle opération n'est évidemment pas
facilité par la concentration spontanée
des rapatriés dans le Midi et n'a de
chances de réussite que par une
dispersion dans tout le pays 250
000 chefs d'entreprises ont su le 18
mars un questionnaire pour recenser les
emplois vacants qui entre le 8 avril et
le 1er mai seront tous bloqués au
bénéfice des rapatriés
c'est un fait que l'économie française
est actuellement en expansion partout de
nouveaux emplois se créent l'intégration
des rapatriés se présente donc comme une
chance supplémentaire de l'économie
cette économie a dit monsieur missof a
besoin de cette main d'oeuvre énergie le
problème des mutations géographiques
vers des régions en expansion concerne
tous les Français les rapatriés n'en
sont que les premiers acteurs et le pays
leur fait confiance
[Musique]
sous les brumes du Pacifique entre
l'océan et la Cordillère des Andes 7 ans
un désert long de 2000 km
seules les fleuves descendants des
montagnes transforment tout à coup en
campagne verdoyante un paysage de
désolation ici du nord au sud la route
panaméricaine traverse le Pérou elle
longe une côte inhospitalière dont
l'étrangeait le voyageur le conduit à
travers le temps au berceau de
civilisation qui sont encore des énigmes
pour l'homme moderne
[Musique]
ces spectacles macabre ne sont que le
résultat de profanation perpétré par des
pillards qui la nuit ouvre des tombes un
violet depuis des millénaires pour y
prendre des bijoux des pierres
précieuses et même certaines poteries
recherchées par les musées de tous les
pays du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corps des morts étaient à cette
époque comme en Égypte enveloppé de
bandelettes souvent tissés avec art et
enfoui dans ce désert aride ces mots my
ont traversé les siècles sans dommage
[Musique]
certains objets usuels aux formes
insolites sont encore quotidiennement
retrouvés intacte après une cinquantaine
de siècles doublés
[Musique]
des monuments élevés par ces peuples
inconnus il reste encore ses pyramides
d'argile séchées qui rappellent les
constructions babyloniennes
[Musique]
que dire de ces curieuses figures
géométriques que seule l'avion nous a
permis de découvrir il y a peu de temps
face au ciel elles offrent une
ordonnance rigoureuse et complexe qui ne
peut être que de la main de l'homme et
dont l'origine est l'utilité échappe
jusqu'à présent aux archéologues du 20e
siècle beaucoup ont remarqué
l'analogique elles offraient avec la
topographie d'un aérodrome moderne
invisible du sol révélé par la photo
aérienne elle furent ignorait des
nombreux peuples qui vécurent là au
cours de l'histoire et notamment des
Incas
l'homme moderne qui se croit le pionnier
de la conquête du ciel devra-t-il
admettre des précurseurs balise
aéronautique ou symbole astronomique
pourquoi ces créatures aux ailes
déployées gravées dans le rock et large
de plusieurs centaines de mètres
[Musique]
qui nous dira ce qu'on veut ces deux
personnages dans leurs auréoles
flamboyantes
[Musique]
le même visage de lumière nous attend
sur la Porte du Soleil à tiwanako le
calendrier astronomique de la planète
Vénus est reproduit exactement sur ses
hauts reliefs et certains ont pu aller
jusqu'à conclure en découvrant ces
personnages volants et ses pistes
mystérieuses que dans ce coin d'Amérique
du Sud avait autrefois vécu une humanité
venue d'un autre monde
[Musique]